はあああああああ
じゃあ弾みさとディ久しぶりに超でかい買い物をしちまった
これ
なんだかを向けいじゃあバッチリ書いてありますね
室内用ウレタン臍マットまあ族デュアルでセーフティーマットって言うんです皆さん
跳び箱の授業とかでやりませんでしたかハンドスプリングやヘッドスプリングをする時
も着地が絶対危ないの確定してるんで普通のパッドじゃなくてこうなんかスカーフ角
バットを使ったことありませんでしょうかそれで上げていこうと思う
[音楽]
片方これじゃない団蔵な刑事に終わっているというの負債がうまい
私はきっと
どうすれば話はどうしようめっちゃ方や
たくてくださいこれですよこの深くかですよ
おおすごいぞ
[音楽]
ああああああ
アーマて一見待ってまつげ待ってまーやキッズのほど得ることもやばいはいという事故
ももちろんあるんですけども
基本的にこういう隙間とかにはまらずそのまませれば絶対安全ですね今まで若干
トラウマになったなぁこれ
幸和町で畔をちゃん送ったへ使えばないところはこっちで
を取った
大丈夫なんです僕わー
まって今痛かったぞ
5分
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
大丈夫だよねえっ
いや大丈夫だと思うもうねぇ日中ときにも使えますこれは今後僕のレッドとしても使え
ますという風に僕ですねこのはセーフティーマット使ってやってみたいことあったん
ですあのちょうど少し前に裏別途作ったじゃないですか家のハシゴを登ってイックぅ
手羽端氷でってはお礼がめんどいんでジャンプでいけたら一番楽なんじゃないかという
わけであのセーフティバントを買ったんです本当はジャンプでおりで
ということはそこから学科さも大丈夫なんで今日の動画は高いところから当然
ジャンピングドッキリしてみようと思いますいつはやってみたかっただけかもそれの
ために買ったみたいなもんなんであり元尖閣をしっかりしてやりたいと思っております
朝イチでやるからね動ける状態なんですけどお楽しみに出会い光景
よ
b
あった
[音楽]
b
ああああああ
結構高いなくって撮影で屋上から飛び降りる撮影したことあるのでこういうのめっちゃ
やったことあるん結構遠くになんですねではやっていきましたが1回練習で積んでみ
ます
ちょっん
困っていますきっと場合供給
でした
あ安全を確保されるやっております決してまでじゃないでくださいではかっ
行ってきます
あにさん便利ですけど
スマブラ大会車
いらっしゃいません
こすってからやるぞあん
いや無田することを買っちゃう
ネット目指すならちょうどいいんですかは確かに高いところへのばいい
調査会社により高いはん
voodoo
パパいえええわあああ
バッハ
[笑い]
[拍手]
ブーブー言っは
me
dea
car
あああああああっ